[Music]
recently had a concussion and I'm
wondering if you if you're okay now
Who I am better thank you for asking I
had the world's lamest concussion cuz I
didn't even hit my head apparently that
can happen I was just about to hit
somebody in their car they were also in
a car yeah two cars two cars and I
stopped I stopped very very suddenly and
and I seatbelt you know stopped me and
my brain like a soapy sponge continued
to slide forward and I hit my own skull
I got a concussion you hit you hit
nothing nothing you you you stopped
quickly a stop and your brain went
forward and hit my own hot Pete on Pete
action smash it's like Krang do you know
who Krang is I don't know who Krang is
I'm sorry I didn't think you would know
who Krang is I asked for a graphic of
Craig did we get a graphic narrative
that is praying inside of his optional
robot bodysuit he's a talking brain that
plots against the Ninja Turtles Oh Ninja
Turtles yes I'm shocked they didn't know
that but well I'd like to think that my
accident was like Krang was inside the
robot suit the robot suit was running
and then stopped and then Krang
ah don't back away from a pretty decent
kraang impression I swear to God
go forward go towards you say so your
brain hit your skull and then Wow did
you get tested afterwards I had to go to
the doctor and I know you've done this
as well I had a concussion on television
they gave me a they asked me they knew I
was in trouble when they were asking me
questions that I couldn't answer well
that's the thing he was gonna give me
the cognition test to see if I had some
sort of brain damage and I told him
before the test started I was like I'm
going to fail this test it has nothing
to do with whether or not I hurt my head
I'm a comedian I exist in a separate
field from you I don't live in your
reality I'm not gonna win right he was
like let's just do it it's really easy I
was like okay he goes what day is it and
I'm like no no sir what month is it I
was like no it's true if you're a
comedian you almost you don't have to
know it's yeah you have to be at a club
to tell jokes at a certain time right
Wednesday feels like what you call
Saturday right all of them are the same
right he goes who's the president and
I'm like ah Obama ha who is the
president before Obama Obama you quack
yeah what I'm saying is I don't know
those things if you want to find out if
a comedian had brain damage you should
ask him something that a comedian should
know like if you asked me to name five
foods I'm angry at yes
and I can't be like Captain Crunch it
cuts up my mouth that's not leadership
expertise order an MRI that's what I'm
saying yeah
if you can't riff on airline food you're
probably bleeding out inside wrong with
the boy yeah